Does shopping bring you joy? Or do you feel a bit of pain or regret every time you have to make a purchase? Many of us will be shopping for gifts in the coming weeks, whether we enjoy it or not. So today we're going to talk about the psychology of shopping. How do our emotions drive our buying behaviors? Why do some people spend money so easily, even when they shouldn't, while others find it difficult to splurge even when they can afford it? Does buying a gift feel the same as buying something for yourself?
购物会给你带来快乐吗？还是说每次购物时，你都会感到一丝痛苦或后悔？在接下来的几周里，无论我们是否乐在其中，许多人都会去购买礼物。所以今天我们要谈谈购物心理学。我们的情绪是如何驱动购买行为的？为什么有些人即使不该花钱也能轻松消费，而另一些人即使负担得起也难以挥霍？买礼物和给自己买东西的感觉一样吗？
Is retail therapy a real thing? Can shopping boost your mood? And why are Black Friday sales so irresistible? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Scott Rick, an associate professor of marketing at the University of Michigan's Ross School of Business.
“零售疗法”真的存在吗？购物能提升情绪吗？为什么“黑色星期五”的促销活动如此令人难以抗拒？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是密歇根大学罗斯商学院的市场营销学副教授斯科特·里克博士。
His research focuses on understanding the emotional causes and consequences of consumer financial decision-making, with a particular interest in the behavior of tightwads and spendthrifts, people who chronically spend more or less money than they want to, or perhaps should. The goal of his work is to understand why consumers behave the way they do and to develop interventions to improve their decision-making and well-being. He has published in journals dedicated to marketing, psychology, management, neuroscience, and economics. and his research has been covered by many media outlets, including the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal,
他的研究专注于理解消费者财务决策的情感起因和后果，特别关注“守财奴”和“挥霍者”的行为，即那些长期花费比自己想要或应该花费的钱更多或更少的人。他工作的目标是了解消费者行为背后的原因，并制定干预措施以改善他们的决策和福祉。他曾在市场营销、心理学、管理学、神经科学和经济学等领域的期刊上发表过文章，他的研究也被《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》等多家媒体报道。
The Washington Post, and NPR. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Rick. Thank you so much for having me. Really happy to be here. One of the things you're known for is developing the tightwad spendthrift scale. So let's start there. We all know that some people spend money more easily than others,
《华盛顿邮报》和美国国家公共电台（NPR）。感谢您参加我们的节目，里克博士。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。您以开发“守财奴-挥霍者量表”而闻名。那我们就从这里开始吧。我们都知道有些人比其他人更容易花钱，
but you found there are real brain and behavioral differences between tightwads and spendthrifts and that they're related to an emotional experience called the pain of paying. Can you tell us more about that research? Yeah, so that started just based on conversations. I'm personally a spendthrift raised by spendthrifts. And, you know, my advisor back in grad school, George Lowenstein, was a tightwad and I was finding a lot of people in my life seemed to be tightwads. They seem to have a lot of distress when thinking about spending money. And that was kind of a strange thing to me, that if anything,
但您发现守财奴和挥霍者之间存在真正的大脑和行为差异，并且它们与一种被称为“支付痛苦”的情感体验有关。您能详细介绍一下这项研究吗？是的，这最初源于一些对话。我本人就是一个由挥霍者抚养长大的挥霍者。而且，我在研究生院时的导师乔治·洛温斯坦是个守财奴，我发现生活中很多人似乎都是守财奴。他们在考虑花钱时似乎会有很多痛苦。这对我来说有点奇怪，因为如果有的话，
my distress came afterwards once I saw like the credit card bill or things like that. So yeah, we did some stuff like have people shop while having their brain scan with functional MRI. And we found some evidence consistent with this idea of a pain of paying that people use feelings of distress as kind of the brakes on the car. So like the more kind of anxious or uncomfortable I am when thinking about spending the money, the less likely I am to do it. Now, some people have too much of that. That's the tight ones. And that could come from lots of places, including maybe there was some financial distress earlier in life that they just can't shake later when their objective financial situation improves. And then there are those of us like spendthrifts who just don't have enough of it.
我的痛苦是在事后，当我看到信用卡账单之类的时候。所以，我们做了一些实验，比如让人们在进行功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）扫描时购物。我们发现了一些证据，支持“支付痛苦”这一观点，即人们利用痛苦感作为汽车的刹车。所以，当我考虑花钱时越焦虑或越不舒服，我就越不可能去花钱。现在，有些人这种感觉太多了，这就是守财奴。这可能源于很多方面，包括可能早年经历过一些财务困境，即使后来客观财务状况改善了，他们也无法摆脱这种阴影。然后就是像我们这样的挥霍者，我们对此感觉不够。
We don't think about spending as mathematically. We're more focused on the present than the future. and so there are these kind of big differences. And we developed a scale, a tightwad spendthrift scale, to measure this and figure out what it's different from. For example, being a tightwad is very different than being a frugal person. A frugal person, they love to save, and it's fun, and they enjoy it, and they're happy. A tightwad just really dislikes spending, and they're not so happy,
我们不会从数学角度去考虑消费。我们更关注现在而不是未来。所以存在这些巨大的差异。我们开发了一个“守财奴-挥霍者量表”来衡量这一点，并找出它与其他概念的区别。例如，成为守财奴与成为一个节俭的人是非常不同的。节俭的人喜欢储蓄，这很有趣，他们乐在其中，并且感到快乐。而守财奴只是非常讨厌花钱，他们并不那么快乐，
and they're not buying the gifts that they should for their partner. and they're not going on the vacations they should, and they're walking around in shoes that hurt, even though they have the money to buy better shoes. And, you know, spend thrifts aren't on cloud nine either. They're often in debt and kind of kicking themselves for spending too much. We do find there's this middle ground of unconflicted consumers who kind of have a reasonable amount of pain when thinking about spending,
他们没有为伴侣购买应有的礼物，也没有去该去的度假，即使有钱买更好的鞋子，他们也穿着磨脚的鞋子走来走去。而且，挥霍者也不在云端之上。他们经常负债累累，因为花钱太多而自责。我们确实发现，中间存在一群“无冲突消费者”，他们在考虑花钱时有一种合理的痛苦感，
and they tend to be happiest. So are most of us somewhere in that middle ground then, where we're neither a tight-wad nor a spendthrift? Yeah, it depends on where you look, but around 50 to 60% of the people we sample are in that big middle ground of the unconflicted consumer. And then it's about equally shared on the extremes. And it sounds like tightwads aren't really getting any pleasure out of accumulating their money, right? I mean, they just have so much pain spending it. So that's the difference?
他们往往是最快乐的。那么我们大多数人是否都处于那个中间地带，既不是守财奴也不是挥霍者？是的，这取决于你观察的对象，但我们抽样调查的人中约有50%到60%处于那个巨大的“无冲突消费者”中间地带。剩下的则大致平均分布在两个极端。听起来守财奴从积累金钱中并没有得到任何快乐，对吧？我的意思是，他们花钱时只是感到非常痛苦。这就是区别吗？
Yeah, it's kind of anxiety maintenance, just a way to kind of calm the fears of going into bankruptcy. And when you listen to a lot of them kind of talk about their feelings and their thoughts, a lot of them do have memories of real distress in the past. And it's just hard to shake it once things get better. This reaction, these feelings are cultivated over time. And it's hard to switch it off, you know, like a light switch. So I think for them it kind of helps to manage the distress kind of holding onto money. Are spending habits related to other aspects of people's personalities, such as overall conscientiousness or extroversion?
是的，这更像是一种焦虑管理，只是为了平息破产的恐惧。当你听他们谈论自己的感受和想法时，很多人确实有过去真正痛苦的记忆。一旦情况好转，这种记忆就很难摆脱。这种反应和感受是随着时间推移而培养出来的。就像电灯开关一样，很难关掉。所以我认为对他们来说，持有金钱有助于管理这种痛苦。消费习惯是否与人们性格的其他方面有关，比如整体的尽责性或外向性？
Or is the tightwads spendthrift trait just its own thing? Yeah, no, it's related to things. So tightwads are more guilt-prone. They're a little more conscientious. It's not kind of just conscientiousness. They're not necessarily flossing more, showing up to meetings on time more often. But there's some relation there. Yeah, and they tend to be a little more mathematical in their thinking.
还是说“守财奴-挥霍者”特质是独立存在的？不，它确实与其他事物有关。守财奴更容易产生内疚感。他们稍微更尽责一些。这不仅仅是尽责性。他们不一定更频繁地使用牙线，也不一定更准时参加会议。但两者之间确实存在一些联系。是的，他们的思维往往更具数学性。
They can't shake the idea of opportunity costs. What am I giving up later? They really do interpret a price tag in terms of what I'm foregoing. And I think they almost kind of blow that up a little bit. Like I'm foregoing like so much by spending now. So yeah, you can see like differences in their college majors. There are some gender differences too. women are a little more likely to be spendthrifts than men are, but it's not just that.
他们无法摆脱机会成本的概念。我以后会放弃什么？他们确实是根据我所放弃的东西来解读价格标签的。我认为他们几乎把这一点放大了。就像我现在花钱是在放弃很多东西一样。所以，你可以看到他们大学专业上的差异。性别差异也存在。女性比男性更有可能是挥霍者，但不仅如此。
It's a small relationship, but it's there. You mentioned college majors. How does that play? So on the Titewad side, you tend to see more kind of engineering, mathematics, whereas on the spendthrift side, you tend to see more social work or social science. But you might be thinking like, oh, well, how does gender relate to this? We even find that within gender, you see these major differences. women who are tightwads are more likely to have majored in engineering and math and women who are
这是一种微弱的关系，但确实存在。您提到了大学专业。这方面有什么影响？在守财奴方面，你往往会看到更多工程、数学背景的人，而在挥霍者方面，你往往会看到更多社会工作或社会科学背景的人。但你可能会想，性别与此有何关系？我们甚至发现，在同一性别内，也存在这些主要差异。身为守财奴的女性更有可能主修工程和数学，而身为
spentthrists are more likely to major in social work and things like that and so that's true for men as well and so yeah there is definitely a different thinking style and there's a lot of people who study emotion who say that there's no emotion without cognition it's all kind of connected and i think the thoughts and the feelings kind of especially for tightwads they kind of build on each other Kind of the distress brings to mind thoughts of what I'm giving up later, which makes you more distress than it's a cycle. So one thing people may be curious about is where these traits come from and how early they develop. And I know you've found evidence of them even in very young children. Can you explain that?
挥霍者的女性更有可能主修社会工作等专业，男性也是如此。所以，确实存在不同的思维方式。许多研究情绪的人认为，没有脱离认知的纯粹情绪，它们都是相互关联的。我认为思想和感受，特别是对于守财奴来说，是相互促进的。痛苦引发了对未来放弃什么的思考，这让你更加痛苦，形成了一个循环。所以人们可能好奇这些特质来自哪里，以及它们多早开始形成。我知道您发现即使在很小的孩子身上也有证据。您能解释一下吗？
So we have developed a scale, a spinthrift type one scale for kids age five to ten. And, you know, it's a very simplified thing, kind of which cartoon character has, feelings towards money that match what you have. And, you know, even there we get kind of a similar looking distribution of scores as we see among adults, kind of a similar amount in the middle, and then you're two extremes. Yeah, so we're looking into how that might transfer from parents to kids through conversation. So we bring these parent-child diads into the lab and have them talk through money situations. And you do see some kind of telltale signs, like I spendthrift parent might be, the kid might want to save, and the spendthrift parent is like,
我们为5到10岁的孩子开发了一个“挥霍者-守财奴量表”。这是一个非常简化的东西，类似于哪种卡通人物对金钱的感受与你相符。即使在那里，我们也得到了与成人相似的得分分布，中间的人数相似，然后是两个极端。是的，我们正在研究这如何通过对话从父母传递给孩子。我们将这些亲子组合带到实验室，让他们讨论金钱情况。你会看到一些明显的迹象，比如挥霍者父母可能想花钱，而孩子可能想存钱，挥霍者父母会说，
well, are you sure? Like, there's some cool stuff here. I can definitely relate to that. But again, you know, a lot of it does seem to date back, at least among adults, to these really formative times in their life when things were really good or really bad and they just can't get past it once things change later. You know, it's been called sometimes a post-brokness stress disorder, like, you know, this idea that, you know, once broke and always broke in terms of your feelings, no matter what your actual
“好吧，你确定吗？这里有一些很酷的东西。”我绝对能感同身受。但同样，很多情况似乎确实可以追溯到，至少在成年人中，追溯到他们生命中那些真正具有形成意义的时期，当时情况要么非常好，要么非常糟糕，一旦后来情况发生变化，他们就无法摆脱这种影响。这有时被称为“破产后应激障碍”，即一旦破产，在你的感受上就永远破产，无论你现在的实际
bank account looks like now. It's there from an early age. I think part of it is kind of the internal wiring, kind of what your guilt-proneness, things like that, what you're born with, what your parents instill, and then kind of just your financial reality as a kid. It calls to mind, though, the marshmallow test with Walter Mitchell and kids who can delay gratification is, is that part of what's going on here as well? I think it is part of that, for sure. And tightwads are certainly better at that kind of thing. But we do find it's not kind of a general patience,
银行账户看起来如何。它从很小的时候就存在了。我认为部分原因是内在的“接线”，比如你的内疚倾向，你与生俱来的东西，父母灌输的东西，以及你小时候的财务现实。这让我想起了沃尔特·米歇尔的“棉花糖实验”，那些能够延迟满足的孩子，这是否也是这里的一部分？我认为这确实是其中的一部分。守财奴当然更擅长那种事情。但我们发现这并不是一种普遍的耐心，
that tightweds aren't necessarily patient in a lot of other domains. It really does seem to be more specific to kind of how they think about parting with money. But, you know, if I had to, if I was forced to kind of bet on who's better able to wait for the second marshmallow, it would be the tightwad child, certainly. So you've looked at how money and spending habits figure in relationships, romantic relationships, and you've found that people actually tend to partner up with their opposite. The tightwads often marry spendthrifts and vice versa. Why does that happen and how does it work out for these couples?
守财奴在许多其他领域并不一定有耐心。这似乎确实更具体地指向他们如何看待花钱这件事。但是，如果我被迫打赌谁更能等待第二块棉花糖，那肯定是守财奴孩子。所以您研究了金钱和消费习惯如何在恋爱关系中发挥作用，并且发现人们实际上倾向于与自己的对立面结合。守财奴经常与挥霍者结婚，反之亦然。为什么会发生这种情况，这对这些夫妇来说结果如何？
So there's a real clear pattern that you see in like sociology research of these patterns of fatal attraction, that if there's something you don't like about yourself, and then you see it in someone else, that that tends to be kind of a real turnoff. It kind of repels you. It's this thing that I'm self-conscious about and then I see someone else, and it's just, ugh, it's enough when it's just me. I can't have a second version of that in the house. And so, you know, at first, it's really fun and exciting to find someone who doesn't have that issue. that you dislike. And we do find that tight ones and spin thrifts
在社会学研究中，有一种非常明显的“致命吸引力”模式，即如果你身上有什么你不喜欢的东西，然后你在别人身上看到了它，那往往会让你感到厌恶。它会排斥你。这是我对自己感到不自在的地方，然后我看到了别人，这太糟糕了，我自己这样就够了。我不能在家里再有一个这样的版本。所以，起初，找到一个没有你所讨厌的那种问题的人，真的很有趣和令人兴奋。我们确实发现守财奴和挥霍者
don't like being tightweds and spendthrifts. They're conflicted. That's why we call the people in the middle unconflicted. And so they tend to pair up more often than you would expect, more often than kind of a tightwad, tightwad couple or a spendthrift spendthrift couple. And so that's fun at first. That's great.
不喜欢成为守财奴和挥霍者。他们是矛盾的。这就是为什么我们称中间的人为“无冲突者”。所以他们比你预期的更容易配对，比守财奴-守财奴夫妇或挥霍者-挥霍者夫妇配对的频率更高。所以起初这很有趣。这很好。
But as often happens with these fatal attractions, things get serious. You have to spend a lot of time with this person and make a lot of big decisions. and about where to move and how many kids to try for and that kind of thing. And we are very consistent with past research and finding that the more different they are over time, the more and more they fight over money and wish they married someone else or just stayed single. I don't think that has to be the case with all mismatched couples.
但正如这些致命吸引力经常发生的那样，事情变得严肃起来。你必须和这个人共度大量时间，并做出许多重大决定。关于搬到哪里，要几个孩子等等。我们与过去的研究非常一致，发现他们随着时间的推移差异越大，他们为钱争吵的次数就越多，越后悔结婚或希望保持单身。我不认为所有不匹配的夫妇都必须如此。
There are ways to, I think, manage those discussions and manage how money flows in the household. But on average, the mismatched partners seem to have a pretty wrong. go of it. So how does some of those interventions work if you're in one of these mismatched relationships? Can you fix it? I think it's good to have discussions and realize, maybe even both take the scale, the tightwad spendthrift scale and figure out where we are and realize that it's not that I'm, you know, if it's a spendthrift talking to a tight one partner, you know, just realize it's not that I
我认为有一些方法可以管理这些讨论并管理家庭中的资金流向。但平均而言，不匹配的伴侣似乎过得相当糟糕。那么，如果你处于这种不匹配的关系中，其中一些干预措施是如何起作用的？你能解决它吗？我认为进行讨论并意识到这一点是很好的，甚至双方都可以做一下“守财奴-挥霍者量表”，找出我们所处的位置，并意识到这并不是说我，
don't care about our future together. It's, it's, you know, that I'm blowing household money and I do care about our future. It's just, I have this quirk and, you know, let's try to find a way to work through it, perhaps with our account structure, like joint versus separate accounts. How obvious do we want our spending to be to each other? Do we both have to know everything right away, or can we have some private fun accounts? And, you know, working with a financial counselor and or a financial therapist, I think, can be a good thing. Certainly financial therapy is becoming a more popular practice. But yeah, it can really be misinterpreted. You know, if I'm a spendthrift and my partner is a tightwad and they get me a really terrible gift, what, you don't love me?
如果是一个挥霍者在和守财奴伴侣交谈，要知道这并不是说我不关心我们的未来。而是，我正在挥霍家庭资金，但我确实关心我们的未来。这只是我有一个怪癖，让我们试着找一种方法来解决它，也许可以通过我们的账户结构，比如联名账户与独立账户。我们希望彼此对消费的了解程度如何？我们是否必须立刻知道一切，还是可以有一些私人的娱乐账户？而且，与财务顾问或财务治疗师合作，我认为是一件好事。当然，财务治疗正成为一种更受欢迎的实践。但是，是的，它真的可能被误解。如果我是挥霍者，我的伴侣是守财奴，他们送了我一份非常糟糕的礼物，什么，你不爱我吗？
No, it's not that. You just are really reluctant to spend money. But, you know, maybe my love language is gifts, but you can't spend the money. And so it can be real confusing. But if I just know that well, it's not a love issue. It's just how you use money. Then there's more understanding there. So, yeah, just opening up the discussion, understanding these tendencies, and finding money flows and discussion tendencies that work for you as a couple. But it sounds like sharing financial information is kind of important here. Even if it's not everything, right? I mean, you should share enough. Enough, yes. I'm all about openness.
不，不是那样的。你只是非常不情愿花钱。但是，也许我的爱的语言是礼物，但你不能花钱。所以这可能会非常令人困惑。但如果我知道这并不是爱的问题，而只是你使用金钱的方式。那么就会有更多的理解。所以，是的，只要开启讨论，理解这些倾向，并找到适合你们作为夫妻的资金流向和讨论倾向。但听起来分享财务信息在这里很重要。即使不是全部，对吧？我的意思是，你应该分享足够的。足够的，是的。我完全支持公开。
But I don't know about kind of 100% immediate and active disclosure of all purchases. I think you can't keep some things to yourself. And yeah, so, you know, a lot of people, for example, have this idea that, you know, the latte factor. Like, oh, if you don't buy the latte at work, then you can save up enough money to buy a home and be fabulously rich and all that. Some people really believe that. And so if they do, maybe I don't want to tell them about the lattes I'm buying because, is it's just going to cause a fight. And the lattes really don't matter that much in the grand scheme of things.
但我不知道是否需要100%立即和主动披露所有购买行为。我认为你不能把一些事情完全留给自己。而且，是的，很多人，例如，有这种想法，即“拿铁因子”。比如，哦，如果你不在工作时买拿铁，那么你就可以存足够的钱买房，变得非常富有等等。有些人真的相信这一点。所以如果他们这样做，也许我不想告诉他们我买拿铁的事，因为这只会导致争吵。而在大局中，拿铁真的没那么重要。
So, yeah, it's openness, good, but maybe there's room for discretion. So you can hide the lattes, but it's a little harder to hide that red corvette. Indeed. So let's talk about gift giving for a minute, since that's a topic that's on listeners' minds right now. And one perhaps surprising finding of yours is that spendthrifts seem to be at a disadvantage when it comes to giving gifts to their loved ones. Why is that? Yeah, I think it's somewhat counterintuitive
所以，是的，公开是好的，但也许有酌情处理的空间。所以你可以隐藏拿铁，但隐藏那辆红色克尔维特就有点难了。确实。那么让我们谈谈送礼，因为这是听众现在关心的话题。您有一个或许令人惊讶的发现，即挥霍者在给亲人送礼时似乎处于劣势。为什么会这样？是的，我认为这在某种程度上是违反直觉的，
because you would think that they would be best positioned to give the best gifts. They're just willing to spend. But the issue is, how do they signal that this is something different or special that I'm doing for you? If I live with a spendthrift and I see them kind of splurging all day, every day,
因为你会认为他们最有能力送出最好的礼物。他们只是愿意花钱。但问题是，他们如何发出信号表明这是我为你做的不同或特别的事情？如果我和一个挥霍者住在一起，我看到他们整天都在挥霍，
and then they splurge on me for a gift, like it's not anything special that they've done. This is just your normal thing. So it becomes hard to kind of signal through normal kind of consumerist, you know, capitalist means that I really do love you. And so I think for the spendthrift, you've got to do something different. You've got to, maybe it's an experience that you kind of carefully plan. Maybe it's something you make. But if it's just something else you pick up in your,
然后他们为我挥霍买了一份礼物，这并不是他们做的什么特别的事情。这只是你的常态。因此，通过正常的消费主义、资本主义手段来发出“我真的爱你”的信号变得很困难。所以我认为对于挥霍者来说，你必须做一些不同的事情。你必须，也许是一次你精心计划的体验。也许是你亲手制作的东西。但如果这只是你在日常挥霍中顺手买的另一件东西，那就不好了。它必须是一种节奏的改变。好吧，让我们更广泛地谈谈节日购物。有没有关于为什么“黑色星期五”和其他“抢购”类促销活动对人们如此不可抗拒的研究？如果人们觉得他们买到了便宜货，他们是否会感到更少的财务痛苦或情感痛苦？当然，价格的框架。相对于某物，这是一个低价。它通常是什么或它应该是什么，我的意思是，这确实有助于减少消费的痛苦。稀缺性是行为和欲望的巨大驱动力。我们想要稀缺的东西。你在幼儿身上也能看到这一点，只要让某样东西看起来稀缺，他们就会渴望它。所以我们想要得到那些稀缺的交易。我确实认为部分原因是错误信息，
daily kind of splurging, that's no good. It has to be a change of pace. Well, let's talk about holiday shopping more generally. Is there any research on why Black Friday and other door buster type sales are so irresistible to people? And do people feel less financial pain or emotional pain if they feel that they're getting a deal? Sure, the framing of price. This is a low price relative to something. What it normally is or what it should be, I mean, that does help reduce the pain of spending. Scarcity is a big driver of behavior and desire. We want scarce things. You see that with young children, too, just making something appear scarce and they just crave it. So we want to get those scarce deals. I do think part of it is just misinformation
并且不了解每天都有各种各样的交易。在黑色星期五这样的日子里，你可以得到一些独特的交易，但在其他周五和一般情况下，也有一些不错的交易。所以我们不需要像踩踏事件那样。只是从历史上看，我们知道情况一直如此。我认为现在的环境非常不同。所以我认为这只是缺乏购物专业知识或信息。我还要补充一点，这只是为了找点事做。
and not understanding the kind of universe of deals that are out there day to day. There are some unique deals that you can get on something like Black Friday, but there are some good deals out there on other Fridays and just in general. So we don't need like a stampede there. It's just historically we know that this has been the case. I think the landscape is very different now. So I think it's just a lack of shopping expertise or information. I would also add that it's just something to do.
你知道，很多人不上班。很多人和家人在一起。如果你刚刚和他们一起度过了感恩节，你可能需要透透气，可以这么说。所以这是一种远离过多家庭时间的方式，我会这么说。有时候，一点点就足够了。好吧，那这就引出了一个关于在线购物的问题。您似乎在暗示每天都有便宜货。那么人们在网上购物时与亲自购物时的行为是否不同，还是同样的心理因素在起作用？
You know, a lot of people are off work. A lot of people are, you know, with their family. And if you've just kind of gone through Thanksgiving with them, you might need some air, so to speak. So it's a way to kind of step away from too much family time, I would say. A little goes a long way sometimes. Well, that kind of raises a question then about online shopping. You seem to be intimating that there are bargains out there every day. So do people behave differently when they shop online versus when they shop in person or are the same psychological factors in play?
嗯，当然，是的，许多相同的因素在起作用，但在线购物，它只是在火上浇油。支付可以变得如此毫不费力。特别是如果你已经保存了所有信息，你知道，只需点击几下就完成了。你甚至不知道发生了什么。这就像你被冲昏了头脑。所以，如果你想控制这一点，你必须设置减速带。你必须，比如，删除你的信息。你知道，不要保存它，注销。
Well, certainly, yeah, many of the same ones are in play, but online shopping, it's just kind of adding fuel to the fire. It's just it can be so effortless to pay. And especially if you have all your information saved already, you know, just kind of a couple clicks and you're out of there. You don't even know what happened. It's just like you get carried away. So, you know, if you want to control that, you've got to put up speed bumps. You've got to, like, erase your information. You know, don't have it, save it, log out.
做像亚马逊那样的“稍后保存”或把它放进我的列表而不是“立即购买”。你知道，尝试强制执行某种等待期。而在商店里，你必须开车去。你必须排队。有很多机会让你重新考虑。但对于许多在线或移动购物来说，它太无缝了。但是，你知道，零售商，实体零售商正在赶上来。
Do, like, the Amazon, you know, save for later or put it in my, like, list instead of buy now. You know, try to enforce some kind of waiting period. Whereas in the store, you have to, like, get in the car. You have to wait in line. Like, there are all these opportunities to second guess it. but with a lot of online or mobile shopping, it's just so seamless. But, you know, the retailers, the in-person retailers are catching up.
有这些亚马逊Go商店，你走进店里时只需刷一下手机，然后你拿起任何你想要的东西，然后直接走出去。没有结账。是的，那是个可怕的想法。是的。所以，你知道，零售商非常擅长让你分心，不去想支付的那一刻。在安娜堡，我们有Vaughn-Mar。它就像中西部的诺德斯特龙百货。
There are these Amazon Go stores where you just kind of swipe your phone when you walk in and then you just pick up whatever you want and you just walk out. There's no checkout. Yeah, that's a scary idea. Yeah. So, you know, retailers are really skilled kind of distracting you from the moment of payment. Here in Ann Arbor, we have Vaughn-Mar. It's like the Nordstrom of the Midwest.
他们的销售助理非常友好，非常健谈。在我去收银台之前，我必须想，好吧，这个周末我要做什么？因为我知道他们会问。我不能只说一些蹩脚的话，比如，嗯，我妻子想的任何事情。我必须有一个故事。而且，当我完成时，我有这些袋子。我甚至不记得付钱了。这就像，发生了什么？
And their sales associates are very nice, very chatty. And before I go to the register, I have to think, well, what am I doing this weekend? Because I know they're going to ask. I can't just say something lame, like, well, whatever my wife kind of thought of. I have to have a story. And, you know, by the time I'm done, I have these bags. I don't even remember paying for it. It's just like, what happened?
所以他们很擅长把你的注意力从掏钱包和实际花了多少钱上转移开。然后还有一些小技巧，比如你走进塔吉特百货，他们有一些那种垃圾小商品的展示。他们引导你，对吧？所以，哦，我只会买一两件这些东西，然后很快你就到了商店后面，你的购物车就满了。
So they're good at kind of taking your attention away from pulling out the wallet and how much you actually spent. And then there are little tricks like you walk into Target, and they've got these little displays of sort of junky stuff. They prime you, right? So, oh, I'll just pick one or two of these things, and then pretty soon you're in the back of the store, and your card is full.
嗯，塔吉特的人，他们是艺术家。我的意思是，他们，是的，这完全是关于购物动力。你想在购物车里放点东西。你想立刻打开钱包，然后人们就会进入一种不同的模式，一种不同的心态。所以是的，你必须在他们一进门时就打破这种封印。然后他们有那些大篮子，对吧？
Well, the Target people, they're artists. I mean, they, yeah, that's all about shopping momentum. You want to get something in the cart. You want to get that wallet opened right away, and then people just get into kind of just a different mode, a different mindset. So yeah, you've got to break the seal as soon as they walk in. And then they've got those big baskets, right?
这，你知道，哦，我会买这个被子，因为这里有足够的空间。篮子非常宽敞，是的。我也从来没遇到过轮子吱吱作响的篮子。这简直是一帆风顺。所以让我们再谈谈礼物。在体验的情感方面，买礼物和给自己买东西一样吗？当你给别人买礼物时，你更有可能还是更不可能经历支付的痛苦？
Which, you know, oh, I'll get this comforter because there's plenty of room in here. The baskets are very accommodating, yes. I've never had one with a squeaky wheel either. It's just smooth sailing. So let's talk about gifts again for a minute. Is buying a gift the same as buying something for yourself in terms of the emotions that you experience. And are you more or less likely to experience the pain of paying when you're you're buying somebody a gift?
我们所有的证据确实表明，买礼物带来的痛苦较小，但还有其他情绪可能在起作用，比如焦虑。他们会喜欢吗？他们会怎么想？这可能是一个压力大得多的体验。它只是更具情感色彩。有焦虑，但也有快乐。我们确实发现守财奴在买礼物时看起来不像守财奴。
All the evidence we have does suggest that it's less painful to buy the gift, but there are other emotions that could be in play, like anxiety. Will they like it? What will they think? It could be a much more stressful experience. It's just more charged. There's anxiety, but there's joy. And we do find that tightwads look less like tightwads when they're buying gifts.
我们刚才说的关于挥霍者买礼物的事情，我认为守财奴处于一个非常好的位置。如果他们平时买便宜的东西，那么他们。然后你为我买了一些非常昂贵的东西，我会说，天哪，我知道这对你来说很难。或者考虑到你平时的消费方式，这对你来说是一个巨大的改变。这太棒了。我其实不确定这是真的，因为如果守财奴在买礼物时没有经历痛苦，那么他们有点得到了太多的赞誉。
What we were saying earlier about the spendthrift buying gifts, I think the tightwads are in a real nice position. Like if they're normally buying cheap things, then they're. then you buy something really fancy for me, I'm like, oh my gosh, I know this was hard for you. Or given how you normally spend, this was a big change for you. That's amazing. I'm actually not sure that's true because if the tightwads don't experience pain when they're buying the gift, then they're kind of getting too much credit there.
所以我认为作为送礼者，他们处于一个很好的位置，因为他们设定了期望。但是，是的，这只是一个非常不同的过程，更具情感色彩。那么对于守财奴和挥霍者来说，像杂货、汽油或必需品这样的日常购买，其情感体验是否与他们购买轻浮或不寻常的东西时一样？是的。对于那些常规或必要的物品，痛苦似乎被削弱或影响较小，因为这些东西只是预期的购买。你确实在可选的物品上看到了两种类型之间最大的差异，那些让你思考的东西，比如，我需要这个吗？
So I think they're in a nice position as gift givers because they've set the expectations. But yeah, it's just a very different process, much more kind of emotionally charged. What about everyday purchases such as groceries or gas or necessities for tightwads and spendthrift is the emotional experience of making everyday purchase the same as when they buy something frivolous or unusual? Yeah. So for things that are routine or necessary, the pain does seem to be muted or less influential because these things are just kind of expected purchases. You really do see the biggest differences between the two types on things that are optional, things that make you think, like, do I need this?
我会喜欢它多久？所以我不会期望他们在汽油、牛奶或商品类东西上的支出有太大差异。但实际上，这是那些看起来可选的东西。当然，营销人员非常擅长将可选的东西包装成必需品或投资。你知道，这不是移动按摩的乐趣。这是一项投资，旨在帮助你的背部
How long will I like it? So I wouldn't expect big differences in what they're spending on gas or milk or, you know, commodity kind of stuff. But really, it's things that seem optional. But of course, marketers are very skilled at framing optional things as necessities or investments. You know, this is not a pleasure of mobile massage. This is an investment to kind of help your back.
感觉更好，你会成为更好的父母、更好的运动员或员工等等。那种框架，对守财奴真的很有效。如果是，哦，好吧，我没那样想过。但挥霍者，他们不需要那个。他们非常擅长将一切视为投资，即使这只是像“哦，我会有个很酷的故事可以讲”这样的投资。这是我们擅长的一件事。我们擅长为购买寻找理由。
feel better and you'll be a better parent and a better athlete or employee or whatever. And that kind of framing, that can really work on tightwads. If it's, oh, well, okay, I didn't think of it like that. But spendthrifts, they don't need that. They're very skilled at viewing everything as an investment, even if it's just an investment and like, oh, I'll have a cool story to tell. That's one thing we are good at. We're good at thinking of reasons for purchasing.
所以“零售疗法”的名声不好，人们利用购物来提神，或者在分手或糟糕的一天后让自己感觉更好。但您做了一些研究，发现至少对某些人来说，零售疗法是有道理的，它确实有好处。您能谈谈吗？我听过所有关于零售疗法的坏话，说它愚蠢、浪费，而且不起作用。而且，作为一个研究情绪和财务决策的学者，这对我来说听起来不对。这似乎与我们所知的关于情感体验的知识不一致。特别是悲伤的体验。所以有很多研究表明，悲伤与“我无法控制自己的命运”的想法有关。
So the idea of retail therapy gets a bad rap, people using shopping to act as a pick-me-up or to make themselves feel better after a breakup or a bad day. But you've done some research that found that at least for some people, there is some truth to the idea of retail therapy, that there's a benefit. Can you talk about that? I've heard all the bad things about retail therapy and how it's foolish and a big waste and it doesn't work. And, you know, as a spender of two studies, emotions, and financial decision making, that just did not sound right to me. It seemed inconsistent with what we know about emotional experience. And in particular, the experience of sadness. So there's a lot of work suggesting that sadness is associated with thoughts of, I'm not in control of my own destiny.
我受制于外部力量、环境、随机的偶然。还有其他研究表明，做出选择，特别是令人愉悦的选择，可以增加你的控制感，即你是自己命运的船长。我想要这个，而不是那个。我负责。所以我们认为，当人们悲伤时，说“是的，这个，而不是那个”，我正在做出选择的体验，可以阻止那些
I am at the mercy of kind of external forces, the environment. random kind of chance. There's also other work suggesting that making choices, especially kind of pleasurable choices, can increase your sense of control, the sense that you are the captain of your own destiny. I want this, not that. I'm in charge. And so we thought that when people are sad that the experience of saying, yes, this, know that, I'm making choices, that could kind of stop those.
“我无法控制，我受制于环境”的想法，我们认为我们可以通过让人们做出这些选择来打断那种糟糕想法和糟糕感受的模式。所以这就是我们所做的。我们做了实验，让人们感到悲伤，让他们看非常悲伤的电影片段。然后我们会让他们做购物选择，或者我们仍然让他们接触产品，但他们不能做出选择，就像浏览一样。我认为浏览也被低估了，但它不是选择。
thoughts of I'm not in control, I'm at the mercy of the environment, and we thought we could interrupt that pattern of bad thoughts and bad feelings by having people make those choices. And so that's what we did. We did experiments where we made people sad, and we had them watch kind of terribly sad film clips. And then we would have them do kind of shopping choices, or we would still expose them the products, but they wouldn't get to make a choice, just like brows. I think browsing is also underrated, but it's not choosing.
所以选择者表现出他们比非选择者更快地摆脱了悲伤，通过对某事行使这种控制权，他们能够更快地克服它。这确实似乎是关于选择的。这似乎不是关于我能获得某种东西。即使是假设的选择，他们仍然更快地摆脱了悲伤。我应该说它对愤怒不起作用。我们没有发现它对愤怒有效。愤怒往往是关于其他人的。
And so the choosers showed that they got over their sadness faster than the non-chusers, that by exercising this control over something, they were able to kind of get over it more quickly. And it really does seem to be about the choosing. It doesn't seem to be about I get to acquire some thing. Even when it's hypothetical choices, they still got over their sadness more quickly. I should say it doesn't work for anger. We didn't find it works for anger. Anger tends to be about other people.
我生你的气。你冤枉了我。如果我的老板对我刻薄，我不确定我能通过购物来消除这种愤怒。对，对。我不会买一双鞋然后感觉更好。是的。我的意思是，是的，你可能会喜欢这双鞋，但我认为你仍然会有那种愤怒。但是，是的，悲伤，确实似乎受到通过做出这些选择而得到缓解的影响。
I'm mad at you. You've wronged me. I'm not sure I can shop that away if my boss is being mean to me. Right, right. I'm not going to buy a pair of shoes and feel better. Yeah. I mean, yeah, you might like the shoes, but I think you're still going to have that anger. But yeah, sadness, that does seem to be affected, helped by making these choices.
当然，免责声明。这是一个长期的解决方案吗？这是你应该在每次感到悲伤时都做的事情吗？我不确定。而且我不认为它必须是一件昂贵的事情。我们发现，同样，即使是假设的选择。所以，你知道，为这种事情给自己设定一个预算。这是一个小预算。
Of course, disclaimer. Is this a long-term solution? Is this something you should do at every kind of paying of sadness? I'm not so sure. And I don't think it needs to be an expensive thing. We found that, again, even for hypothetical choices. So, you know, give yourself a budget for this kind of thing. This is a small budget.
这，你知道，比如一顿不错的餐厅饭菜应该是我们处理的上限，我认为。因为，你知道，如果你继续这样做并且负债累累，那么这本身就会让你悲伤，我们不希望那样。但我认为如果明智地使用，购物可以成为悲伤的一个不错的补救措施。那么，您的研究议程接下来是什么？您现在试图回答什么问题？更深入地研究什么对婚姻最好，联名账户还是独立账户，以及对于不同类型的夫妇，包括收入差异很大的夫妇。你知道，你如何管理那些收入差异？有很多旧的研究表明联名账户对夫妇有好处。但那些旧的研究无法排除
This is, you know, like a nice restaurant meal should be like the max, I think, that we're dealing with. Because, you know, if you keep doing this and you get in, in debt, and then that itself will make you sad, and we don't want that. But I think used judiciously, shopping can be a nice remedy for sadness. Well, so what's next on your research agenda? What questions are you trying to answer now? Looking into more deeply this idea of what is best for marriage, joint or separate accounts, and for different kind of couples, including couples that make very different income. You know, how do you manage those income differences? There was a lot of old work suggesting that joint accounts are good for couples. But that older work could not rule out the
这种可能性，即，嗯，也许只是更幸福的夫妇选择了联名账户。比如我们，我们真的很爱对方，我们打算长久相处，让我们合并一切。所以我们所做的，以及我们现在正在撰写的，我们对有独立账户的订婚和新婚夫妇进行了这项实地实验。我们随机分配他们保持独立或建立一个联名账户，只使用那个账户，或者做任何你想做的事。我们跟踪了他们两年。
possibility that, well, maybe it's just happier couples that chose the joint accounts. Like we're, we really love each other, we're in it for the long haul, let's merge everything. So what we did, and what we're kind of writing up now, we did this field experiment with engaged in newlywed couples who had separate accounts. And we randomly assign them to kind of keep it separate or make a joint account and just use that or do whatever you want. And we followed them for two years.
我们发现，我们强制要求使用联名账户的夫妇，两年后他们最幸福。两年后，他们在财务问题上最能达成共识。所以这至少是在对我们的实验持开放态度的夫妇中，他们至少，我认为，在考虑也许我们应该联名
And what we found was that the couples that we kind of forced to do the joint account, they were happiest two years later. They were most seeing eye to eye on financial matters two years later. And so this is at least among couples who were open to our experiment, they were at least, I think, toying with the idea of maybe should we go joint
而我们只是强制他们去做，去做吧。这确实有帮助。我不认为每对夫妇都应该联名。外面有一些糟糕的夫妇，事情有点，你知道，不稳定，对吧？当然。所以也许最好，你知道，
and we just kind of force them to do it, just do it. And it helped. I don't think every couple should go joint. There are some bad couples out there where things are kind of, you know, shaky, right? Sure. So maybe best to kind of, you know,
留一条后路，可以这么说。但是，是的，所以我们正在研究联名账户可能有所帮助的其他一些情况。我们正在更多地研究诸如已经讨论过的“破产后应激障碍”，即早年那些财务困境的形成性经历如何伴随你，以及可以做些什么来让人们理解，比如，哦，我现在确实有钱。我确实有钱可以花。情况还可以。我可以摆脱那种焦虑感。是的。当然，关于父母和孩子的研究还有很多
keep one foot out the door, so to speak. But, yeah, so we're looking into some other situations in which joint accounts might help. We're looking more into things like the post-broken stress disorder that's been discussed, kind of how those formative experiences of financial strife early in life can stick with you and what can be done to kind of get people to understand, like, oh, I do have money now. I do have money to spend. Things are okay. I can kind of shake those feelings of anxiety. Yeah. And of course, a lot of work on parents and kids still to be
要做。好吧，里克博士，这真的非常非常引人入胜。我希望人们在管理财务方面得到了一些好的信息。再次感谢，这真的很有趣。感谢您今天抽出时间。非常感谢。如果您想了解自己在“守财奴-挥霍者量表”上的位置，可以在我们网站www.speakingofpsychology.org的节目说明中找到链接。您也可以在那里找到之前的剧集，或者前往Apple、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是speaking of psychology，全部连在一起，at apa.org。
done. Well, Dr. Rick, this has been really, really fascinating. I hope people have gotten some good information regarding how they're managing their finances. And again, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you taking the time today. Thank you so much. If you'd like to find out where you fall on the tightwad spendthrift scale, you can find a link in the show notes on our website at www.spinkingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes there, or go to Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Speaking of Psychology》由Lee Winerman制作。我们的音频编辑是Chris Condiion。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。